público
[Música]
bienvenidos a un nuevo capítulo de
historia hoy vamos a revisar la guerra
de siria a propósito de los 10 años que
cumple este conflicto
en el año 2011 siria concentraba una
población de 22 millones de personas con
diversidad de culturas y credos
religiosos en su mayoría árabes de fe
musulmana en aquel año el país contaba
cuatro décadas de régimen autoritario de
la dinastía al asad hafez el padre y
bashar el hijo su sucesor quienes
gobernaron con mano de hierro amparados
en un prolongado estado de emergencia
con la ola de manifestaciones masivas de
2011 conocida como la primavera árabe
países como túnez y egipto lograron
derrocar a sus líderes autoritarios ben
alí y hosni mubarak respectivamente
quienes llevaban décadas en el poder en
siria había incertidumbre de un
resultado igual ahora bien el primer
episodio crítico se registró en marzo de
2011 en dar a una ciudad al sur de
damasco allí varios estudiantes fueron
arrestados por pintar grafitis en contra
de bashar al asad la policía secreta
llamada mujabarat torturo a estos
jóvenes y luego masacró a sus familiares
se apoderó de los habitantes de dar a
quienes salieron en masa a protestar y
cuyo sentir se expandió a otras ciudades
como homs damasco y alepo la respuesta
de bachar al asad a la protesta social
fue la de militarizar muy rápidamente el
país y contener con extrema violencia a
los manifestantes tres meses después del
estallido social en junio de 2011
aumentaron los entierros de
manifestantes así como los
desplazamientos de refugiados hacia
turquía es el mismo momento en que según
el observatorio sirio de derechos
humanos decenas de miles de soldados
desertaron de las fuerzas armadas y se
concentraron en zonas rurales para
formar una guerrilla de oposición a
bashar al-assad llamada el ejército
libre de siria estos rebeldes
antigubernamentales fueron presuntamente
financiados por países del golfo como
arabia saudita kuwait qatar y emiratos
árabes unidos- quien es apoyado en la
caída de bachar al asad por ser un líder
de credo alauita
rama del chiísmo en un país
mayoritariamente habitado por sunitas en
contraparte la república islámica de
irán férreo enemigo de arabia saudita
apoyo a al asad no sólo como
reciprocidad por el apoyo prestado por
parte de los sirios en la guerra de irán
contra irak en 1982 sino también para
defender la permanencia del chiísmo en
el gobierno de damasco a finales de 2011
células de radicales islamistas de irak
cruzaron la frontera hacia siria para
crear el frente de la victoria al nusrat
estos radicales islamistas de irak
próximos a al qaeda reclutaron a miles
de radicales islamistas en siria y de
esta forma renovaron la organización
estado islámico un grupo terrorista que
ejecutó una cruenta guerra contra el
gobierno de al assad contra la población
civil y contra todo aquello que no fuera
musulmán en 2012 se saltó de las marchas
a la confrontación directa la ciudad de
homs fue sitiada en febrero de ese año
y en julio estalló la batalla de alepo
en la milenaria metrópoli siria las
confrontaciones se replicaron en otras
ciudades como rac a hamás las afueras de
damasco y prácticamente todo el
territorio se trataba de dos bloques uno
conformado por los rebeldes entre los
que batallaban el ejército libre de
siria el frente al pnud ra facciones
islámicas como al qaeda y facciones
kurdas del gpg en el otro bloque las
fuerzas armadas leales a bashar al-assad
a las cuales se sumaron las fuerzas del
grupo hezbollah proveniente del líbano
declarados enemigos de israel ambas
partes tanto rebeldes como las fuerzas
leales al gobierno son responsabilizadas
por organismos como human rights watch y
amnistía internacional del asesinato
indiscriminado de decenas de miles de
civiles y la violación sistemática de
los derechos humanos pero la degradación
del conflicto llegó con dos componentes
uno los bombardeos químicos y las bombas
de racimo de al asad
los horribles crímenes perpetrados por
el estado islámico ante la dominación
del despiadado estado islámico en el
norte de siria zona que controlaba a
mediados de 2014 y donde proclamó un
califato eeuu decidió el 10 de
septiembre del mismo año entrar en la
guerra bajo la premisa de la lucha
contra el terrorismo varios otros países
conformaron una coalición para apoyar la
tarea de eeuu en el bombardeo de
enclaves yihadistas como la ciudad de
raqqa y en el apoyo militar a las
facciones kurdas las principales
afectadas por el devastador paso del
estado islámico sólo hasta diciembre de
el presidente de trump dijo haber ganado
la guerra contra aquella organización si
eeuu entró en la guerra en 2014 también
lo hizo rusia el 30 de septiembre de
2015 a petición de bachar al-assad su
gran aliado en medio oriente cabe
recordar la importancia de siria para la
geopolítica rusa teniendo en cuenta la
base naval de tartus un enclave
estratégico en territorio sirio que mira
al mar mediterráneo el apoyo ruso y
también el chino a las fuerzas
gubernamentales sirias fue fundamental
para que bajara al asad retomará en
diciembre de 2016 el control de alepo
también para que en 2018 volviera a
controlar el 70 por ciento del país a
excepción de un reducto de rebeldes en
la región de idlib que trae a escena la
ocupación turca del norte de siria para
impedir a toda costa el paso de millones
de kurdos y la creación de un estado del
kurdistán
actualmente siria no se parece en nada a
lo que era hace 10 años ahora es un país
en ruinas con un lastre de 500.000
muertos 67 millones de desplazados
internos y 56 millones de exiliados así
llegamos al final soy andrés suárez
jaramillo gracias por compartir y
comentar estas historias que las
encuentran en los programas de france 24
punto com
ah